I literally have no idea what these men
are doing wrong in this video I that's
what I was thinking what are they even
doing why would a man be there why would
a man be there no it's actually pissing
me off oh my God it pisses me off then
go to a female gym go to like a yoga
class or something what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger but in her case it
looks like natural selection took over
no she does don't need my help why I got
to be me
for what up guys welcome to the just cly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in
let's get started so today I am going to
be reacting to men are refusing to help
modern women let's go
I literally have no idea what these men
are doing wrong in this video I that's
what I was thinking what are they even
doing they try to talk to you bother you
harass you did one of them try to maybe
record a video of you or are you
attacking men for simply existing in the
gym because why don't these chicks just
go to a women's only gym they have those
like why do you go to a man a man's gym
if you're going to complain about it all
I see in this video is a bunch of men
and women working their butts off in the
gym minding their own business yet you
want to make a video to attack their
behavior and call them clowns the only
clown-like behavior in this video that
doesn't belong in the gym is you you
need to do better mind your own business
why would a man be there why would a man
be there no it's actually pissing me off
oh my God it pisses me off then go to a
female gym go to like a yoga class or
something a man be there why do
you want to be there like hello gents
welcome to this episode I think you guys
have noticed this toxic Trend where
women in the gym shame men for merely
glancing at them these chicks don't even
go to the gym regularly they just go for
attention and I mean she she's not like
wearing any clothes you know men for
social media clicks views likes and
clout dudes get labeled as a creep or a
stalker or even a weirdo for merely
glancing at their direction for a
millisecond the most ironic part is
they're crying about a man glancing
their way at the gym while they're
literally putting their video on social
media for thous of people to and they're
half naked some have of pages and for
just $5 a month you can see every angle
of her body uh because of this toxicity
some men have totally stopped going to
the gym and they have opted for a home
gym research says sales of gym
equipments have soared mostly from home
fitness sales also the majority of men
at these commercial gyms have stopped
helping women in the gyms let's have a
look at some few videos all right you
guys today we are going to be looking at
this girl who's training for the Darin
award today she got stuck under the bar
and last time she got stuck in the
washing machine until her step brother
helped her out the safety bars are set
low not as low as her IQ level but
higher than her stand oh my God that's
four men the poor girl looks as helpless
as a turtle on his back but the
difference is a turtle would never be
stupid enough to have his mouth covered
while fighting for his life it looks
like the barbell is trying yeah they're
like this girl's got a leg tattoo and a
mask on I avoiding this one avoiding to
get her pregnant against her will the
camera and the tripod need to be held
accountable for not helping and just
looking in her Direction what doesn't
kill you makes you stronger but in her
case it looks like natural selection
took over no she do don't need my help
why I got to be me for back up back up
back up set back up bro if you're not
scared of help her just go help her I'm
busy you don't see me doing a set how
about you go help why just cuz she has a
tripod you're not going to help her no
I'm doing a set you're not doing a set
so go help her but she literally asked
for someone stronger and you're strong
you do more weight me cuz I could I
tried to help her and I so there's a lot
of stronger than you no off
but not much you're a big guy bro you're
big
[Music]
guy I'm I'm actually impressed that's a
lot of weight
wow yeah the guys really are tired of
being filmed ladies they're really sick
of this they're like I'm just here
to work out I'm looking down the whole
time I am not dealing with this stuff I
am glad nobody immediately responded to
hers the envir enironment that is now
created and Men self-preservation is in
high demand a lot of women do not care
about lives they destroy with their BS
it's no longer worth it to do something
good only to have it manifest itself
into something bad don't help this kind
of woke women at the gym trust me it's
not worth your life dignity and face
just leave them alone and give them what
they asked for also there was this
incident that happened a few years ago
where a man saved a woman from drowning
and uh she went ahead and filed charges
for CP are the article says a
23-year-old woman said she would not be
dropping charges she pressed against a
man who saved her life after she almost
drowned in a pool during a pool party in
her neighborhood Kim Wright said David
took advantage of her when she was
helpless and she wants Justice uh uh
this is the stupidest thing I've ever
heard in my life she wait is arguing
that David should have let someone else
rescue her she pointed that out he was
playing with her breast and she woke up
was probably because of his bad breath
that shows DAV a 29-year-old web
developer uh pulling Kim out of the
water pressing her chest a few times and
giving her mouth to mouth before she
coughs back into life will be used as
evidence against David in court Kim is
arguing that David should have let
someone else rescue her uh she pointed
out that he was playing with her breasts
and the reason she woke up is okay how
else is he supposed to have didn't you
guys have CPR class in high school how
else are you because of the foul smell
of David's mouth to be honest when I
first saw this I thought it was kind of
a joke um but this really happened if
David was a good-look 6 feet six figure
Chad this would have ended differently I
I honestly think the social contract
that once existed between men and women
no longer exists the days where a man
should give up his seat on a Lifeboat or
take any risk to his safety peace or
freedom to Aid a random woman are long
in the past there is no reason to help
our modern-day strong independent Don't
Need No Man women just like they've
monetized love and affection it's time
to put a fee on any assistance they may
require yeah oh my gosh what if all the
ways that men help women were like
monetized you know cuz like women like
I'd imagine if a woman's on the side of
the road and she her car breaks down a
man's more willing to stop and help than
if like a woman than if it was another
guy but yeah what if that stuff was
monetized it's like an interesting
concept guys let me know what you think
in the comments like the video on your
way out and get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today none of
this would happen if women didn't get
the right to vote in the description
like the video we'll talk to you next
time